大家新年好 今天是新年最后一天了
那个15 然后给大家拜个晚年
其实今天早上我讲了一下市场
在客户之间讲了一下市场
但是我忘记录了 所以我现在重新录一次
然后因为已经有两个多星期没说了
然后也想给大家一个update
因为最近的环境变化还是非常大了
然后基本的市场的判断和方向
和我们的仓位 其实我并没有做改变
但是因为最近的市场变化很大
我觉得其实有必要跟大家再说一下
然后让大家看一下接下去可能的交易的一个方向
然后接下去关注的一个焦点
那么首先我觉得我要对于我们其实
在上两个星期的时候讲到的就是
我们叫做tell risk的问题
upside tell risk和downside tell risk
我会增加这么一个概念
今年整体市场的方向还是
我觉得是decompiling
就是美国日本的货币政策去追它的经济发展
然后中国和欧洲它的财政政策
去追中国经济的衰退或者是通缩
那么这个decompiling还是存在的
那么在这个decompiling中间
比较好的标记 比较有预期的标记
当然是美国的资产
但是问题是回来
就是说在美国的资产有这样的市场的预期的情况下
美国的政策是不确定
Talanto政策最近已经证明了
就招令不叫招令袭改
就是它政策的随意性 波动性
然后突然性 非常的大
然后给市场带来了很多的噪音
那么我们会认为说
我改变一下我tell risk的看法
就是这个tell risk是存在
伪布风险是存在upside tell risk和downside tell risk
怎么说呢
就是特别你现在在美国的话
美国市场可能经济增长都不错
然后它会有伪布的风险
有移民政策影响
有关税政策影响
可能有控制巴解deogee造成
然后有欧洲的事情会影响它
那么甚至市场的预期很大
我这加了个mark expectation
市场预期很大
市场预期没达到
那么它就有可能要跌
那么但是跌了以后
它可能整个趋势还是不错的
会回来
但是同时的话
欧洲和中国受到很多政策反面的影响
这个政策反面影响是让它比方说关税
比方说关税现在还没开始
欧洲还没开始搞
那中国的话你搞了10%
那么对中国中美关系不知道怎么样
然后特朗普关税的一些预期
让中国资产在今年年初的时候
跌了很多
那么后面会不会有个upside risk
觉得事情没事了
那么relief了之后
那个upside risk可能会暴涨
欧洲4月份的时候
也会面临同样的关税的问题
那么在这个之后
可能落地的没有这么严苛
那么它可能关税的回头
让它有个upside risk
其实这个市场就是会存在一个
非常大的波动
那么这个中间并不会像2023年
2024年有这么明确的交易的方向
就这个方向很明显
就是投美股投美国
那么我对于现在这个市场的方向
还是没有没有说能够给到全仓
我觉得现在市场的状态更多的
还是守住戴图
等待市场时机
然后我们要认清这有upside risk
tail risk
那回头说一个
我对于upside tail risk
就是我觉得可能会暴涨
那么这种东西的一个看法
比方说你看港股
港股现在已经开始出现
这种upside tail risk的这个这个方
这个一个迹象
那么上两星期有很多有问到
是不是港股可以参与
或者中概可以参与
那我觉得确实
如果你是短期的交易
你可以去参与他
但是我不会大贪婚的去参与
那比方说港股中间比较好的
那个小米的股票
那小米的问题是
小米是一个很不错的公司
也是在港股我能够推崇的
没为己的公司之一
但是问题是小米的手机和汽车
它的产能都在这个
都在过剩的这个环境下
中国整体经济三个大山
都没有卖过去
你可以看到人口
我们最近看到的人口数据
人口下降百分之五
这里没有没有画出那个徒来
但是人口下降百分之二十
就结婚的人数
每年下降将近百分之二十
意味着这个人口下降和人口减少
他的这个通缩的大因子
是不是以年为级
是decade以十年为级的
所以中国伴随着通缩的这个
或通缩或经济变差
或经济增长变弱
那这个趋势是非常非常长的
在这个大长趋势中间
中线的趋势
这意味着就是说后面的
然后说房地产泡沫破灭
加上中国债务过高
这个是短线和中线的趋势
也没有改变
也就是说我在短线里面
140万亿的存款
可能170万亿的贷款
140万亿存款
大部分在有钱人手上
然后百分之一百分之二的手上
但是贷款在
可能四一到七亿城镇居民头上
基本上平均的分布人
那么整个是整个系统性的债务过高
系统性的私营部门收入过低
42%
那么美国可能80%
那么这整个系统性的问题
它能解决吗
它解决不了
然后再加上产能过剩
那么中美关系你说
美国现在给中国只加了10%的关税
但是加了10%的关税
是增还是增加了10%的关税吧
那我们后面一年的日子
会比前面一年好过还是难过
肯定会更难过
而且这个关税的问题
我大伙会继续在深入说一下
可能未必是10%
可能会最后到20%
那么在这个过程中间
我们的趋势性是往下的
但是对于特朗普
对中国的关税政策的预期
中国资产估值过低
或者是之前压了过低
那会不会有遇龙很大的反弹
特别是特朗普
你们会看到前两周的时候
他加关税的时候
针对的是加拿大和Mexico
就加拿大和墨西哥为主
先对了加拿大和墨西哥上
然后中国只加了10%
所以再加上中国政策省
可能财政政策
会去追一下他的通缩
那么中国印了不少的钱
从去年9月份开始
一直在印钱
印了不少的钱
所以中国的CPI
又至此新的CPI
又回到0.5
这个虽然这个CPI的数字
你可以去相信他
会不相信他
但是编辑上来说
他CPI确实是会比
前几个月好一点
那么在这个编辑变好
或者是预期回暖的情况下
是不是会有个upside
tel risk往上的tel risk
我觉得是存在的
那么是否参与呢
这个每个人
对于自己持仓的长短
来自己决定
但是我是不是
他会太大程度参与
因为趋势还是在往下的
所以当下tel risk发生的时候
我觉得是一个
很明确的超级的标题
那么但是upside
tel risk发生的时候
去由于你自己的
持仓的长短
所以今年的大的周期
会有这两方面的风险
就不光是往上往下
还有这种被压制过头的
比如中国
欧洲
他有可能会有往上的
这个趋势
那么对于经济数据
来看的话
是这样子
我最近包括在推特上
讲经济数据
其实已经没有那么多了
那么主要原因呢
去年
刚那个图也是说的
去年是看市场
就是看经济数据
我们要去验证
是不是一个
就美国是不是能够在
高息环境下
倾存下来
经济能够
继续比较强的发展
那么这是MacBook的市场
前年是AI的市场
AI是不是能够带动
大量的kipads
然后带动这个公司盈利
带动科技公司的kipads
那这个被验证
去年的通胀能被控制
经济能够发展
其实也被验证
今年更大的验证
或者市场最最大的关注
其实是政策
那么在这段时间的政策里面
最主要的政策是tariff
是关税
那回顾一下最近发生的关税
所以经济数据
你可以看到
能房配合虽然比较差
但是这两天市场
可能明一下也没有那么大
那么为什么呢
因为能房配合这个数据
有很就就业数据
相比前几年的话
它有很大的这个noise
有更多的这个噪音会发生
那么这个噪音存在于
比方说immigration
移民
存在于短期里面的一些因素
第一次的话
可能有那个大货
有天气过冷
那这些因素
都会让它的噪音变得更大
但是整体的经济数据的趋势
跟我们之前一直预测的
经济数据趋势基本相近的
那么就是在18万左右
所以上一次可能好很多
这一次可能差一点
但是它的fratuation
它的那个波动变大的同时
它的趋势并没有很大的变化
也就是我还是会认为
美国经济现在的状态
就是我们看更加宏观
更加长期的状态
虽然失业率上升了
就失业率
就是失业率是4.0
比那个预期4.0要好一点
但是那个能房配合变了更差了一点
但我们会看到
它的趋势是
失业率维持相对比较稳定
然后我们会看到
它的这个通胀
是能够慢慢被得到控制
但是这中间带
这是大的形式和base case
那么这中间带来可能的变数
再说这个收三的这个cpi
我觉得基本上也会inline
就是这个也会和预期差不多
所以再看已有的
过去的宏观的数据的同时
更加重要的是
看特朗普的政策和他的政策
可能会导致什么东西
那么回到说关税
关税呢
那个导致的市场很大的波动
包括比特币市场
那个有一天他给墨西哥和
墨西哥和墨西哥和加拿大
去加税的时候
其实币权先反映了
然后美股再反映
有很大的这个波动
这个跌幅
那么但是你看teloff的问题
本质是这样看
就说他最后又又又又去谈判
然后又把这个东西又把回来
然后市场又涨回来
其实这个都都可以认为
是市场的一个noise
一个噪音
就是特朗普政府的政策
在关税上其实存在两种关税
第一种关税是目标性的关税
我认为是目标性的关税
就是他拿这个大棒去恐吓别人
然后让别人去跟他谈判
或者他在这个谈判中间
要获得一些其他的东西
那么这是第一部分
except of all出来的关税
其实现在还有第二部分的关税
我们待会说的是更为广泛的一关税
是只在降低美国经常项目
经常项目赤字
或者是美国的这个
那个贸易不平衡的这个关税
所以这两部分关税
会结合慢慢产生效果
那么在第一部分刚刚出来的
那个目标性的关税
刚刚出来的时候
市场会产生恐慌
那么在他解决的时候
市场有relief
现在有个relief的情绪
那么这是不是代表的关税
或者对市场影响
或者特朗普政策
对市场影响结束
我觉得肯定不是
我这边个人的看法是相对来说
为什么我说继续守住带兔
就是我觉得关税的影响并没有结束
你可以看这次的关税的一个闹剧
就是说包括他对中国
也说邮政不能够计
美国邮政不能计
然后前天又说美国邮政又可以计了
包括他对于关税
对于墨西哥和加拿大加25%
然后中国只加了10%
其实目的性很简单
他对于加拿大和对于墨西哥
他的诉求和他一样
他对于墨西哥的诉求更多的是两方面
我觉得我个人感觉
第一个是对于非法移民
你要去控制
因为在美国方面
你去控制非法移民
这是他的政治上重大在肩的
重大的这个认证
那么你在美国方面
去控制非法移民
没有那么容易
那么但是你让墨西哥去控制
别等于他一直说的
我见我
然后我要墨西哥出钱
其实就是变相的
向墨西哥去帮他控制非法移民
完成他的移民政策
第二我觉得也是很重要的
就是他如果要对中国加关税
美国整个关税和贸易不平衡政策
针对的目标就是中国
那么在对中国加税的时候
他先要把在2019年之后
中国在全世界各地建立
避免关税的这些主体给你全家断掉
所以他不加Universal的Terror
不加更广泛的关税
他是没有办法防治能管
特别像墨西哥
很多都是转口贸易
所以就是中国厂商在里开厂
所以他需要把墨西哥跟中国切断
这是一个谈判的筹码
那么对加拿大可能还有其他的
就比方我认我要Digital Service Tax
加拿大加拿百分之三
特朗普是明确的把屁股
做在硅谷是一边的
在硅谷上面来说
那些高科技公司
你在加拿大背说百分之三
你才两千多万人
如果在欧洲也背收
欧洲也在加Digital Service Tax
只是欧盟没有达成一致
所以他有点
最大的三个贸易伙伴先搞
但是他有一点杀击给我看
就是我给到加拿大一个很大的
Digital Service Tax
给到加拿大很大的关税
然让他在Digital Service Tax
和其他议程上做让步
让你们先服了
然后我在整体统筹关税的影响
所以最终就说
加拿大和墨西哥最大的贸易伙伴
他的关税的影响
我觉得是没有结束
他一直要到
US Canada和Mexico的
Trade Agreement
就是贸易的协定
完全完成
那么这个可能要到2016年
所以中间会有来来回回的闹剧
就今天给你postpone了
然后给你那个之后了
然后明天可能之后结束了
又给你开启了
这是一个谈判的过程
我不怀疑最终能达成协议
但是这过程中间的会有波动
就是这个波动就导致了
被压制方的那个猛跌
跌完以后
可能有upside的tail risk
对吧
然后美国这边你发生这些事情
他就会当sale tail risk
给大家看
我在1月份的时候
年初的时候
我做过一个自己的小的预测
我觉得3月份
第一季度的时候
是6000到6100点
微涨
美股就是涨了
涨了涨了涨一点
那个6000到6100
但是不代表最后可能到6100
中间的过程是来来回回很大的
那确实
我觉得基本上
我还维持这个预测
市场也跟我预测的方向
差不多的方向在走
那回到那个tariff的问题
它更广泛的tariff会怎么放呢
现在有一个walk team
就walk stream在做这个美国account in balance
就是这个经常项目不平衡的这个归因
然后呢
要归出美国的这些这个贸易赤字
到底是哪里来的
然后只在减少美国贸易赤字
那这个配合着
包括标定性的关税的
跟墨西哥和加拿大的谈判
这次很有意思
它是microbial的
美国国务卿加上财政部
加上商务部一起谈
所以你会看到这个谈判
并不光光是关税目标的
它是连接着各种东西
跟你一起去谈判的
它是要连着你的政治的战队
包括你跟中国怎么谈
你包括你自己
那个digital service tax怎么样
你对美国科技公司准录是怎么样的
那这个
包括甚至你意识性谈
用加拿大非常非常左
所以这些东西的谈判
可能是一体化的一个谈判
那么这个东西就代表着
它现在把关税作为外交政策的一部分
那么同样更广放的关税
它一定不会是针对墨西哥加拿大
然后我觉得可能对中国
还会加10%
所以现在当然港股在反台了
就最近我觉得
中国的upside risk
upside的这个机会
可能是存在的
然后现在当然走了一半
还没到底
但是我们不想派过
派过深渔深度的去参与的问题是
当时我参与的时候
在港股在1800点
9月9月份的时候在1800点
它的幅度到2300点是挺大的
现在的已经基本上快到前高了
就其实前几天的话
你也到2100
2100的时候
18000点不好意思
就是你现在也在2100
甚至到现在进加更加高
那么再有这样幅度的上涨
其实估值已经不便宜
但是从中国整体经济的这个状态来说
你说它这个估值
pricing它的通缩了吗
没有
pricing的它一部分的通缩
但是没有完全pricing中国
更长周期经济上的通缩
而且这个更长周期经济上的通缩
包括它的税务的政策
关税政策对中国肯定是不利的
这个10%还是加上去
只是比预期少
还有可能还加10%
包括美国还有叫recipical tariff
就是说谁对美国收缩关税
我要反加你
你如果我贸易制裁
你反弹
你也要制裁我
那我把你制裁的
再给你加在你头上
所以会有这样一系列的政策
对于不同国家不同政策
但是整体要全部加关税的
美国的状态
我觉得就是会有反弹
但是这个反弹的幅度不太确定
现在进去的价位
安全性没有那么的高
当然可能会有人涨幅了
但是后面还有很大不确定性
这个不确定性时间点也很紧
比方说更广泛的关税
我觉得可能是4月份就开始
3月底4月份就可能会提交议会
可能会形成政策
然后进行讨论
但是现在市场有没有pressing
没有完全
对于中国
我觉得是10%到20%
对于autotex就比方说
对于欧洲的autotex
可能还会出来25%
这一些的影响
我觉得可能都是会是负面
所以对于在一个下降趋势中间的
中国和欧洲的资产
每次都会有反弹的机会
大家如果是比较短线的话
是可以参与的
但是如果像我这样
就是相对来说
更长线的厚的投资人的话
那么我觉得更多的可以去
以不是特别高的仓位
等待美国可能会发生的一些事情
然后再进入民国的资产
因为经济上的decapital
经济上的风化
每日对中欧的风化
我觉得今年会持续
明年会持续
甚至在一个更长的周期里面
也会持续
日本可能会加入美欧日
中欧日
但是美国的趋势还是会比较好
那么整个市场短期来看的话
其实是这样子
从特朗普上台的时候
市场相对来说是比较紧张的
特别是对于关税
那么美元一直在涨
美国利率也一直在升
其实最高的话
美国利率10年期
利率到4.8
然后美元上升
对于欧元基本上到1比1
那么在最近这一段时间
对于关税有个relief
就是有一个松弛
对于这个松弛之后修复了美国利率
而且美国利率有两个原因
我其实在1月份也讲到了
就是4.7 4.8
我觉得到头过分
就是你难道还能定价美联储去降息吗
美联储去升息
我觉得不至于
然后我也说到
2月份 3月份的美国国债的供应
相对来说是比较少的
虽然我们看到10年期供应
就星期三
但是整个的规模
我们说DEO1的规模
相对来说比1月份是要少很多的
那么你这样看这个市场
整个国利率的市场
利率不会在2、3月份
90升了太高
所以这个是一个松弛期
松弛期的时候
你看到美元相对来说走弱
然后日元欧元的话走强
美国利率升4.8到4.5
但是你回头如果去看
整个市场对美国利率定价
那个一年期的话
是降一至到两次吧
4.4%
但是两年三年是不降的
这个就是市场对于美国长期
维持更好的利率的一个
Factation预期
但是对于欧洲
对于英国
别看
它都是有一个明确的降期的预期的
所以你可以看美国在一个顺风船上
也就是所有看到的欧元
日元除外
日元有一些特殊性
日元有两方面
一个日本的Inflation Expectation比较高
第二方面的美国特朗普政策
对于日本可能是
不一定是加关税
可能是要求它的汇率维持稳定
这是非常有可能的
所以抛开日元不说
比方说是人民币和欧元
它其实是逆水行舟
那么在现在美元relief
就是松弛的这个阶段
加上4月份的贩有性的关税
可能会出来的情况下
我觉得就是说
从利率上来讲
美国4.5到4.7
还是我看的正常的空间
就是我当时在4.8的时候
也说4.5到4.7
那现在回到4.5
我还是看4.5到4.7
就是今年这个趋势
今年不像去年这么紧
这么紧的意思
有发那么多的债
然后国债收益率
那个会被一直拉上去
没有
所以这个相对来说
流动性对于包括比特币
那个流动性的资产
会稍微好一点
但是并没有很松
在4.5到4.7
美元还会继续走墙
所以现在这当市场
没有完全去pricing
去定价那个欧洲
可能会发生的这个贸易战
那个我们觉得3次月份
可能会发生就是
对两个说
欧洲的特别是auto
对那个汽车去征税的情况
那么我觉得可以去
在挖挥上
可以去买美元
两个月的shadow
买个帽
这个波动率现在的
那个realizable
都已经比pricing
pricable要更高了
那这个是就短期里面的一个
我觉得交易上
外汇上交易给机会
那么利率同样
4月份的供应也会上去
所以我们有一个
特别恐慌的1月份的季节
美元在走墙
利率在走高
然后那个因为供应一面
因为市场的平付
在这两个月就恢复
但是我觉得4月份的时候
又会回到那个状态
所以你会看到
政策性的推动
它就会来来回回来来回回的
给到市场这些信号
那么那个在中间
就是会波动会大很多
那么这两个星期
其实还有一个比较重要的
那个对市场影响比较重要
比较大的一个信号
就是大公司的业绩
那我在
我记得我在春节前
讲到过就是大公司
要回答一个核心的问题
是我的马菌
在不停的
CAPEX投入的时候
一定是带下降的
那么我在马菌下降的时候
我对CAPEX决心有多少
这个问题取决了整个三
就是整个半导体
整个半导体过去几年
都是围绕的AI
AI带动的是
Data Center的投入
就是数据或数据中心的投入
数据中心投入带来了
大量的半导体的投入
所以半导体的毛利很高
然后半导体四大云厂投入
就是对半导体带来了增长的估值
那么这个问题是一个非常难的问题
而且这个对于四大云厂
马菌和CAPEX
那这个问题会持续的问到四大云厂
那么在这一次的业绩
因为这一次业绩正好还连带了Deep Seek
我待会讲一下Deep Seek
然后连带了Deep Seek的时候
给到市场
所以市场的不知道四大云厂
会不会有很大决心
因为Deep Seek看上去成本很低
那我是不是还继续投云的
那么四大云厂给出的结果是
会继续有极大的决心投入云业物
Amazon100个别领
然后Google其实我买它60到65吧
那么这个投入对于给到市场
就说今年的决心还是非常大
所以很有可能的是说
在半导体比方说英伟大
它在今年的业绩确定性还是很高
虽然有Gb200的各种各样的
72张片各种各样的问题
连接各种案问题
包括他们现在都在调试
但是他可以变8块片
然后他们可以把单转到Gb300去
新的Gb300可能也就是
今年年终就要出片了
所以我去年前年
投入了很多Infinstructure基础设施
那么这些基础设施
慢慢都完成了以后
它今年要去投金片
总的增长到20到30
那么这个的Kapax投入的增长
大部分是跌到芯片的
对应于英伟达业绩达50%
就是1200亿到2000亿
那多少
我们这50亿上
这样的一个增长
对于这个确定性是很高的
也就是说英伟达今年可能是5块钱
所有的Semiconductor都没有问题
就可能最近在一个反弹的周期
但是你记得我之前可能一年前
我就说我持有英伟达
可能就只会持有到今年
一季度爆出来
我本来是希望说
在四季度和一季度的时候
Gb200这些问题都能解决
英伟达有个很
就是你看到这么大的投入的需求
有个很光明的高点
能让我在180到200跑掉
那么但是问题现在
可能Gb200还有一些小问题
那么今年的季度性的业绩
有一些不确定性
全年业绩全年性很高
但是我是觉得
因为英伟的业务
不再是一个无脑业务
也就是今年虽然还有30%的增量
但是你可以看到
包括这个预期
四季度的预期差
预期和世纪的差
其实S&P的差的没有那么大
就说我们预期已经越来越满了
第二个
这边我可能没有个数据
就是Magnificent 7
原来过去几年
远远抽出493
就是除了7个大公司以外
7000余以外的公司
它的Earning Growth
就是盈利的增长
差别的有多大呢
有30个点
过去是30个
一年前是30个点
这次季报是7个点
2026年可能是3个点
这中间带动的就是
Earning Growth的一业继的增长
其实我们投了那么多的云厂
包括是四大云厂
包括高货机公司
它的AI应用层还没有发生
对 我们一直说SARS
包括软件层
其实我们都是觉得AI应用层要发生
AI应用层如果没有发生的话
他们没有办法去回答我码卷
就是投资的码卷
这个公司的码卷
则是我不停做开盘的这个问题
这个问题在今年会一直被询问
这一次我表现决心
下一次也表现决心
到了2026年的时候
你跟S&P500其他公司的差别
没有那么大的时候
你是不是继续表示这么大的决心呢
战略上他们是正确的
因为我是觉得整个AI给到的算力革命
是并行算力取代串行算力
串行算力就CPU
CPU是需要每个晶片
都是需要越来越精进
但是问题是摩尔定律是有上限的
但是你从串行算力
变成并行算力的时候
其实你是包括Kuda
Kuda是包括Kuda
它其实是一个指令级
GPU算力是一个并行的
它会要有一个新的开发环境
新的开发语言
所以在这个新的东西刚出来的时候
那么Kuda和那个英伟达
是迟到了第一波最大的红利
你可以把Kuda想成有点像什么
有点像对应于当时的Ka86的这种架构
它有很多很多的命令指定级
全在这个里面
但是随着并行算力越来越成熟
它后面是非常有可能会有ARM的架构
就是一个更加精简的
精简算子的架构
现在其实在Data Center
在那个数据中心中间
大家也都在开发各种各样的ASIC算力
因为有很多我常用的东西
然后说广告推荐算法
我就可以把它精简到ASIC里面去
那谷歌做TPU做了很长时间一直在做
那么Amazon的云业务
就是它的这个广告业务也在上升
它我对Trinium 3没有那么
今年它弄出来明耀排程
没有那么乐观
比方说这个
但是它的那个ASIC的需求也会越来越大
因为ASIC明确的成本会比原来
你通用的GPU要便宜很多
所以你像英伟达的业绩
你明年整个市场很难再有20%的增长
就算大家非常有决心
今年给到30%增长
明年大家非常有决心
给到20%
你的一部分市场份额必然会被ASIC吃掉
被他们自己去设用的那些
你就把它想成一个常用的调用级
常用的这个算法归在一起做成ASIC
你一定会被ASIC吃掉
所以你的增长可能只有15%
20%
然后或者20% 30%
但是你同时的话
你的马顶在下降
英伟达没有办法避免他的这个毛利下降
特别是他现在这么高的毛利
那个这么高的毛利的下降
是很难避免
你75降到70
或者你降到65
你如果是降到65的话
你马进在下降
你的增速在下降
对于英伟达这样的公司
我觉得是会
下明年的话
是会有很大很大的风险
所以你就回过头来说英伟达这个值仓
我觉得就这个美股的值仓和美股公司的投资
我觉得Data Santa的投资并不是一个无脑投资
那么这个投资可能是需要找到他更高编辑的一个投资
DeepSeq有没有影响到这些Data Santa的需求
我觉得没有
DeepSeq我个人的理解可能跟很多的人的想法不太一样
就是他是一个开源的模型
挑战了一个没有开源的东西
但是DeepSeq训练的时候
确实用了GPT的输入
就GPT的输出等于是我逆向工程
我做到提
你把答案告诉我
把答案反推了这个过程
但是他在这过程中间给你做了优化
我发觉你这个解法好像有点绕
我给你做了一下优化
简单就这么回事
但是他成本很低
但是DeepSeq不是一个孤立
也就是说包括李飞飞团队做出S1
S1我忘了是50万
50万还是50块钱美元
好像是50万
50万美元
所以就能够训练出SE来
所以整个训练的成本
是市场上的成本
被它直接降到DeepSeq为最低点
DeepSeq并不是说我厉害了我的国
而是说他开源把整个市场的成本
市场的下限降到了DeepSeq
所以结果对应的就是OpenAI
把O3 mini给它降了97%的价格
降了97% 降到了3%
所以它给市场带来
市场就知道了OpenAI原来非常非常赚钱
它卖API非常非常赚钱
但是这个的影响就是市场上
原来很多觉得成本还是很高
想去尝试AI还没有尝试的人
会有更多人去尝试
所以整个市场对酸力的需求
还是一样存在
你说DeepSeq有没有训练能力
他连训练盟都没有找到
它是印象工程
你解之道题怎么解怎么去测试
他这不知道的
对训练对于大集群训练
10万亿级参数的模型的训练
还是需要Navillian的芯片
在这个赛道里面
因为它是无可匹敌的
我只说它估值不一定能指到这个价
它是30VP还是20VP的问题
它的margin降了
它的增速降了
它可能拿不到30VP
但是它在模型训练这一块
它还是无可匹敌
OpenAI也只有这一条路走
就是我更快的训练出更好的模型
虽然你能够很快的把我抄出来
但是我更快训练更好模型
然后出来的时候
我就把成本加下来
我出来的时候就给更低的成本
那就没有你DeepSeq或者是你的什么事
所以这个过程中间
我们其实是
我觉得是一个工业革命级的Mass adoption
这个Mass adoption是可能会给到更多的公司
去尝试AI的机会
会跑出来
现在还没有跑出来
真正的应用
包括我Mass adoption投资的那个TEM
它看上去是一个医疗
就是医生用的GPT
它有数据
有医疗
有其他业务
但是这个是它的最大的闪光点
就是医生用GPT
是不是它一定能跑出来
其实是不一定的
我们不知道
我举个例子
就互联网上
你其实并不知道互联网出来
能搭建网站很便宜
最后跑出来是黄叶
还是亚户
还是谷歌
还是谁
最后跑出来的甚者是不清楚的
但是我们知道
这个是一个工业革命级的东西
所以大家都会用
所以在算力革命上
那个创意型算力
变成并性算力
这件事情是确定的
并性算力大规模的增加
这也是确定的
所以Data Center的投资
虽然大家大家决心怎么打
可能明年增速没有那么多
但是我们在中间找到
它的这个找到它中间
编辑效应更高的点
我觉得这还是主要的投资方向
所以我归纳下来其实是两个
大家在应用的时候
就是会需要用到SARS
会需要把那个
我先要把数据传到云端去
然后我要调用这个SARS
然后我才能去做训练
我现在终于自己能搭建一个模型
然后我把数据全放上云
所以SARS云
然后这是一个方面
因为这是工业革命级的Mass adoption
所必须的东西
第二部分就是那个
在数据户业务中间的一些编辑效应
比英伟达更高的东西
比方说Ezac
比方说连接
具体的名字我们这里就可能不展开
但是这个是我对美股后面的一个看法
那么第三个就是
讲一下美国除了Telof以外的一些的风险
就是大家可能关注到就是七个小匠
一个大学毕业的六个高中生
直接把USA的给关掉了
在关掉USA的这个过程中间
那个Elon Musk关掉USA的中间之后
他们要去搞国防部
所以你可以看到Telof说
我增加那个我减少赤字
我其实像降本增效
我现在是要增效
然后他没有做大规模的这个政府
雇员的裁员
但USA的是整个关掉
这些人都会裁掉
但是这个导比现在的程度
能不能让美国经济变成就是
脱裂美国经济呢
我觉得现在还没有
但是要尽管起变
看Elon Musk最后他们做最后的结果是怎么样
包括Ministry of Spending
因为你政府所有Spending出去的钱
其实都会变成GDP
当然A的到外面去不算
但是这个国防部是肯定会变成Spending
他是把原来的代表比方说
雷神陆坑·皮拉马丁
这些军工复合体
是被替换成潘贴相关的
进攻复合体呢
还是说把这种成分给砍掉
就是你要去看
但是我更倾向于相信
就是特朗普可能会把一部分的Spending
给替换掉
就是可能会变成军工
所以我们刚刚讲到云
然后云SARS
然后在Edge中间比较
Edge中间比较有编辑效率的行业
还有就是新的军工复合体
Parentia相关的那些公司
那我觉得我到时候可能在圈里面
会整理一个大致的名单
然后我们可以去去观察这些公司
就是这个是尺碑级的规模
因为你要知道它是小米的汽车
为什么能够比得过那个BMW的汽车
因为BMW的一个汽车
它从定型到需要三年
它有各种各样的供货商
它是一个ODB种线
理念的各种供货商
小米是Consumer Electronic
它可能几个月就做出来了
它用的是系统
就和当年苹果去替代诺基亚一样
苹果替代诺基亚
比如说不是硬件
它是系统替代
它的系统替代着NOGEC的系统
那我们现在看到
包括耳误打仗
是Parentia的系统比俄国人的系统好
是AI的系统
计算机打赢了你
是软件整理
那么一样
那么美国国防部的这个采购
它其实也是做了同样的路径
就是我觉得原来的采购
就是腐败太多
花了太多的钱
不需要这么贵的F35
可能无人机能解决问题
那我对于新的能够进到
国防订单的一些公司
比方说无人机
指挥车
或者是机器人
或者是软件系统
或者是整体控制系统
那些东西取代了
原来的坦克大炮
或者是部分取代坦克大炮
或者升级改造坦克大炮
所以国防新国防
新军工在美国
我觉得也是尽量的机会
所以这个三个方向
可能是我个人
会比较关注的三个方向
然后大致的宏观上的情况
我觉得还是我之前预期的
就是一个比较波动的市场
这个波动市场中间会不停的存在
upside risk和downside risk
如果说是做一个比较
持稳的投资人
我们要知道
你要去抓一个死猫跳到反弹
是很困难
那当然了
像中概股见到
你看到他开始要准备死猫跳
推进去
但是我觉得更好的一个方向
是跟着趋势走
中国的趋势是往下
美国趋势是往上
那么在这个中国趋势
死猫跳反弹
马上反弹了
反弹上去以后
那么就可以把舱位进行
清完以后
根据舱位清完以后
就是可能接下去的
美国是会有下跌
因为美国它不停的政策的调整
包括加税加关税
加低OgE
都会带来很多不确定性
只要下跌的时候
我觉得都是会有机会
这么大的美国spending
这是整个美国spending的比喻
你觉得它能不能够减少2万亿
我其实个人觉得不太可能
那么在特朗普
只要没有规模性的
减少美国发债的规模
让发债规模比方说
真的是减少2万亿
或者是几万亿的这种规模的情况下
美国的经济的基本面的方向
并没有变化
就是它增效可以
但是不能减短
减得太厉害
这个是我们要观察的OgE
但是一路马斯克
这个人到底做成什么样的东西
其实不知道了
所以就是DOG
当然永远还是一个很大的问号
很大的不确定性
所以在风险中并行
加上另外有可能会影响市场的信息
就是比方说德国可能会下下周会选举
下周会选举
所以这也会增加很多的不确定性
所以在uncertain中间
我觉得是capture这种一个dip
不管是往上还是往下的dip
然后去做交易
好吧
这个大概是我回顾一下
或许两周整体的市场一个情况
我的预设是又复述了一遍
前面的今天早上的这个会议
因为今天早上会忘记录了
然后谢谢大家给大家拜个年
另外最后我忘记讲的
就是如果特朗普的政策
就现在来看
我们看到他的政策
我刚刚预测那些关税政策
我算了算
全部可能实现的话
对于通胀会不会有影响
会有影响
PC可能会加0.5
所以这个也是
但是这PC增加0.5
已经很大程度上
在inflation swap上面反映了
所以你可以看到inflation swap
比特朗普上台说上升了0.6%
所以你很难说
比方说在9月份的时候
很悲观的时候inflation swap是正确的
所以我觉得
但是如果他没有出特别出格的政策
宏观的
就会有很大波动
但是宏观趋势
现在还没有看到
就是宏观趋势上
变很大恶化的这个挺好
0.5并没有那么严重
然后而且市场已经pricing了
就说定价了
就说美国利息可能会维持
相对来说比较平稳的高位
I have for longer
每个将一两自信
所以这已经在pricing中间
所以只要不理由急议
搞出经济
几个衰退
也大规模的裁员搞出经济衰退
我觉得现在基本上还在
baseline的paceline
就baseline基本的paceline里面再走
我会每周跟大家
继续update一个这个情况
然后
谢谢大家
新年快乐